I think the smartest way is to recognize
that if this is I won right which has an
X sine X on a bottle of life and this is
like two which has a minus X sine X on
blah blah when you put these two
together rather than dealing with them
separately right these guys are going to
cancel that's really good right so
here's the way that I started working I
said I 1 plus I 2 what's it going to be
equal to
it's 2 integrals but they share the same
boundary and boundaries I'm gonna share
the same variable of integration so I
can just combine them ok so this is what
I get
ok so you can see my X sine X is cancel
this guy and this guy right so now we
should get this now a small number of
you got a little too enthusiastic with
your cancelling out of terms and your X
sine X and your XO X they cancelled and
that's sine X also just disappeared so
or you end up here with PI and I was
like oh ok that's a shame because it
drastically simplifies the question so
even though this is something I should
mention to you if any of you have this
we've talked about this before you know
what that means it means you vent error
and you carried it through but
everything else was correct
ok I'm a small portion of you and I
don't know if any of you actually
sitting here if it's other people whose
papers are there if you ever see me
write this this is a lesson of a common
code but it's still an important one
right sometimes you can make an error
early on in your working such as this
one you know leaving off the sign X
right that's an error that you carry on
now even if you do it everything
correctly from here as soon as pie or
mumbles cos squared ok even if you do
everything correctly the area of
introduced has simplified the question
dramatically so you don't just lose one
mark you'll lose more because you're not
doing the same amount of work that
everyone else is you've made an error
and you made it simpler ok so you've got
to watch out for those they're nasty now
once you get to here which is
you can either see that you can use your
best straight channels straight away or
maybe if you're a little concern because
of boundaries or so on you can say let
new people cause X and then you can go
from there do you want me to keep on
showing you how that works or do you
think that's enough show you yes no okay
I'll really quickly do negative sine X
so you get new boundaries the lower
boundary becomes this your upper
boundary becomes this or by the way that
was a place where some areas crept in
people saw this right and they sweat
straight from x equals 0 to u equals 0
which was a big mistake clearly right I
think because people got confused
between which function was actually you
because I think we all know that closed
zero is one but you know your rush you
see that together and you have to be
very careful ok um right so once you've
done this you can check that PI out the
front and you'll have oh yes that's
right it is a bit unusual that your
lower boundary lower boundary is bigger
than your upper boundary right but
that's ok we know how to deal with this
in integration right you go from 1 to
negative 1 but you've got a negative up
here right so I can use that to turn the
boundary around so you get this the
boundaries look like they're going back
the way that you're used to right so
that's 10 universe and some of you did
go straight to 10 inverse of cos x and
that was fun okay so what are we gonna
get you're gonna get PI because this is
gonna be um this is minus tan inverse of
negative 1 minus tan inverse of negative
1 that's a lot of minuses but you can
see that's what makes them
and that's where you get this okay one
last night before you leave this
question there was a free mark at the
end of Part A which some of you threw
away because you ended up being confused
at parts 1 2 & 3 patois asks you to
evaluate the original integral like this
right but being that you already know so
much information you've had to prove so
many steps earlier on right it was like
two lines or three lines I suppose we
know what this result is i1 plus i2
right because we just rektd our kids but
I squared but we also know that I want I
to are the same right so this is
actually two times i1 right my 1 plus i1
on that side so you just had to divide
by 2 that's all so there's an exam
technique for you when you are rushed
and confused and don't know what else to
do but a scram to around 4 marks look
for those multi-part questions often the
last part is just trivial it just
depends on you using the previous parts
properly that's all